right 7/8 as a decimal and so the main
realization here is that 7 over 8 is the
same thing as 7 divided by 7 divided by
8 which is the same thing as 7 divided
by 8 these are all the same way of
different ways of writing the same thing
so let's actually divide 8 into 7 and
I'll do it down here just so I have some
more real estate to work with I'm going
to divide 8 into 7 and I'm going to add
a decimal point here just because we
know that this value is going to be less
than 1 7/8 is less than 1 we're going to
have we're going to have some digits
beyond or to the right of the decimal
point and let me put the decimal point
right up here right above the decimal
point in 7 and then we start dividing
and now this really turns into a long
division problem and we just have to
make sure we keep track of the decimal
sign so 8 goes into it doesn't go into 7
at all but it does go into 70 so 8 goes
into 70 8 times 8 times so it goes into
70 it goes into 70 8 times 8 times 8 is
64 and then you subtract 70 minus 64 is
6 and then bring down another zero
because we still have a remainder we
want to get to the point that we have no
remainders assuming this thing doesn't
repeat forever and then there's other
ways we can deal with that 8 goes into
60 well let's see 8 it doesn't go into
it 8 times because that's 64 8 goes into
60 7 times 7 times 7 times 8 is 56 56
and then we subtract again 60-56 is 4
and now we can bring down another zero
right over here and 8 goes into 40 well
it goes into 40 exactly 5 times 5 times
8 is 40 and we have nothing we have
nothing left over and so we're done 7
divided by 8 or 7 eighths is equal to 7
divided by 8 which is equal to 0.875 but
I'll put a leading zero here just so it
makes it clear that there's that this is
where the decimal is 0.87
five and we are done